hey 42 here in the deepest darkest
depths of the frigid North Atlantic
Ocean lies a one-point two square
kilometre island called Hans Island and
Canada in Denmark just can't help but
put their sticky hands all over Hans
Island lies directly in the middle of
nurse Strait which separates Canada from
Greenland Greenland as you may know is
an overseas territory owned by Denmark
since 1930 there has been an ongoing
dispute between the Canadian and Danish
government over who owns this small
barren island in the middle of
absolutely nowhere you see under
international law which is just fancy
terminology for the Pirates code all
countries have the right to claim any
land within 12 miles of their coastline
since the nurse Strait which Hans Island
sits in is only 22 miles wide that puts
the island within 12 miles of both
Greenland and Canada meaning they both
have a claim to it so who actually owns
it well I'm sorry Canada but the island
was officially ruled to be Danish
territory by the permanent Court of
international justice of the League of
Nations in 1933 however shortly
afterwards the League of Nations was
abolished which made them really regret
calling it the permanent Court it was
replaced with the United Nations after
which Denmark's claim to Hans Island was
kind of forgotten by every other nation
since it no longer carried any weight
Canada subsequently told Denmark to keep
their hands off Hans Island and the two
have been bickering about it ever since
luckily Canada and Denmark are fairly
peaceful nations and this long-running
dispute is often settled in a humorous
manner in 1984 Denmark's Minister of
Greenland Affairs visited Hans Island
and stuck a Danish flag in it at the
base of the flag he left a note that
read
welcome to the Danish Island he also
left a bottle of brandy this marked the
start of the so-called whiskey war
between the two nations ever since that
day the two nations militaries have been
randomly sailing to Hans Island where
placing the other nations flag with
their own and leaving a bottle of
whiskey and a sign saying Eva welcome to
Canada
or welcome to Denmark Danish ambassador
Peter Jensen said whenever the Danish
visit the island they leave a bottle of
schnapps and the Canadians apparently
leave a bottle of Canadian Club whisky
it's like the coldest cold war that ever
happened now this may all seem a bit
silly for two countries arguing over
land but to me it seems a lot more
mature than nuclear warheads uncertainly
a lot funnier too but even Canada and
Denmark recognize that it may not all be
snaps and giggles forever the two
nations see it as a friendly but
long-standing dispute and they both
admit it has potential to cause friction
in the future especially since melting
ice caps makes the Arctic Circle an ever
increasingly attractive place for trade
route between certain countries so there
are currently plans to turn Hans island
into a condominium which would mean it
is collectively owned by both countries
so basically they have to share and no
more whiskey or sarcastic signs thanks
for watching
there really is absolutely nothing going
on in there scientists have discovered
that the beloved koala bear may be the
least intelligent mammal on the planet
this tower of testosterone is Danish
man-beast Peter Freudian he is the most
interesting man in the world